in this video you're going to learn how
to work with fractions so we're going to
take a look at fractions mixed numbers
adding subtracting multiplying and
dividing
go ahead and take a screenshot or pause
this video and try to attempt these
eight problems on your own and we'll go
through them and talk about some of the
different ways to solve these problems
okay so the first problem you can see we
have an addition problem 3 7 plus 9 14
the key thing when you're adding or
subtracting fractions is to get a common
denominator and what does it mean to get
a common denominator so you look at that
number in the bottom of the fraction and
you ask yourself what's the
lowest common denominator or another way
of saying that is what's the smallest
number that 7 would divide into and 14
would also divide into
now in this case you can see that they
both would divide into 14 evenly without
any remainder so once you recognize that
you can say well how do i get both
fractions to have a denominator of 14.
well three-sevenths if we multiply the
numerator by two and the denominator by
two that's like multiplying the whole
fraction by one
and because two divided by two is one so
now when you multiply horizontally
across 3 times 2 is 6 7 times 2 is 14
and then 9 14 that already has a
denominator of 14.
so all we have to do now is add the
numerators 6 plus 9 is 15 and you keep
that denominator of 14. sometimes
students make a mistake they try to add
those together and say 28 but you just
keep that common denominator 14 but the
only issue here is that the numerator is
larger than the denominator that's
considered an improper fraction
so what you want to do is you want to
say how many times does 14 go in to 15
that's one whole time
with one left over so we say 1 and 1 14
and that's your answer okay for number
two what did you get when you solve this
one 5 6 minus 3 15. well again it's the
same approach you want to look at the
denominator and you say hmm what's the
lowest common denominator or another way
to say it a little bit different than
the last problem is what's the least
common multiple meaning if we were to
take multiples of the number six like
six times one
six times two six times three just keep
adding six or
taking basically multiples of six
and you can go as as you know as far as
you want and then take a look at that
second number 15 and look at multiples
of 15. so 15 times 1 is 15 15 times 2 is
30 15 times 3 is 45 you keep going until
you get a common multiple so one in
common and here you can see that
we have a common multiple of
30. that's the lowest one that they have
in common so what you would do there is
you'd say okay we want to get both
fractions to have a denominator of 30.
so if i look at 5 6 what do i have to
multiply
the numerator and denominator by to get
a denominator of 30. well you can see
that's going to be 5
because 6 times 5 is 30 and the
numerator 5 times 5 is 25 so we
basically converted 5 6
into 25 30 same fraction just a
different denominator and we'll do the
same thing with 3 15. so we're going to
multiply the denominator by 2
so we get 30 in the in the bottom if we
multiply the denominator by 2 you want
to multiply the numerator by 2 3 times 2
is 6. so now both fractions have a
denominator of 30
and we're subtracting so we have 25 30
minus 6 30 which is equal to
19 30 and that's your final result okay
for number three we're switching gears
here to multiplication so we've got 4 9
times 27 tenths
now you can do this a couple different
ways you can multiply horizontally
across like 4 times 27 and 9 times 10.
so let's do that the first way now
that's not necessarily the easiest way
but sometimes that's a quick way to do
it so 9 times 10 is 90. 4 times 27 is
108
90 goes into 108 one full time
with 18 left over and then you can
reduce the 18 90ths let's see 8 i'm
sorry 9 goes into 18 twice and 9 goes
into 90 10 times and 2 goes into 2 once
and 2 goes into 10 five times so we just
reduce that down and we're getting one
and one-fifth
but another way to do this is to make
use of what they call
cross-reducing or what you can basically
do is you can reduce any numerator with
any denominator okay so either top and
bottom like this
or on the diagonals so you could say
maybe like 4 and 10 is there something
that goes into both of those or
27 and 9 is there something that goes
into both of those so you can reduce top
and bottom or on the diagonals let's go
ahead and do that so 9 goes into 9 once
9 goes into 27 3 times
2 goes into 4 twice and 2 goes into 10
five times
now when we multiply across see the 2
times 3 gives us 6
1 times 5 gives us 5 and so you can see
we're getting 6 fifths which remember
five goes into six one time with one
left over
so we're getting one and one fifth the
exact same thing we got when we did it
the other way just multiplying across so
a couple different options i like the
reducing numerator and denominator or on
the diagonals just because it makes the
numbers a little bit smaller and a
little bit easier to work with okay
number four we're switching gears now to
division
and when you divide
this is what you want to remember is
that you keep it change it flip it so
what does that mean it means you keep
that first fraction you change the
division sign to multiplication and you
take the reciprocal of the second
fraction here you flip it over
once you do that now you're just like
the previous problem it's a
multiplication problem you can
multiply horizontally across so i could
do 7 times 3 is 21 over 15 times 2 which
is 30. that's one option and then reduce
but what i like to do is i like to see
hmm is there anything that can reduce
numerator and denominator numerator and
denominator or on the diagonals well in
this case i can see 3 and 15 they both
have a 3 in common so 3 goes in here
once
3 goes into 15 5 times
now when i multiply horizontally across
i get 7 times one is seven five times
two is ten and it's already reduced for
me seven tenths okay now for number five
we're getting into problems involving
mixed numbers so it's a part whole part
fraction right
so there's a couple different ways to do
these problems and i'm gonna show you
different ways you can pick the one that
you like one way to do it is to
convert these into improper fractions so
what you would do is you would take the
denominator 5 multiply it by the whole
number 4
add it to the numerator there too so
it'd be 5 times 4 is 20
plus 2 is 22 all over 5. you keep the
same denominator let's do that again
with the 3 and 9 tenths so you say 10
times 3 is 30
plus 9 is 39 all over that same
denominator 10. so now you can see we've
got
two fractions okay we don't have a mixed
number anymore two improper fractions
but we have to get that common
denominator so we can say hmm what's the
smallest number that five and ten both
go into it looks like 10 is the smallest
number they both go into
this second fraction already has a
denominator of 10. so let's make this
first fraction have a denominator of 10
by multiplying the numerator and
denominator by 2. so that will give us
44 tenths
plus 39 tenths
now if we add the numerators we're going
to get
83
and you keep the common denominator 10.
so 83 tenths now this is an improper
fraction so we have to say how many
times does 10 go into 83 what goes in
eight whole times
with three left over so our answer is
eight and three tenths
okay now you're saying mario what's the
other way right
the other way is
you can stack these
vertically okay instead of doing the
problem horizontally so what you can do
is you can write them one above each
other kind of like this you could say
four and two-fifths
plus three and
tenths and what we're going to do now is
i'm just going to get a common
denominator with the two-fifths and the
nine-tenths so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to say hmm 5 and 10. we want a
common denominator of 10. so i'm going
to multiply the top and bottom by 2.
so that's giving us four tenths
and so now four tenths plus nine tenths
is 13 tenths and then what i'm going to
do is i'm going to add straight down
here with the whole numbers the four and
the three is giving us seven
but you can see we still have a little
bit of an issue here the 13 tenths
that's an improper fraction
so how many times does 10 go into 13
that's 1
with 3 left over so it's 1 3 10 but
remember we got to add that 7 to it
so 7 plus one and three tenths is going
to give us
eight
whole and three tenths is the fractional
part so we have eight three-tenths eight
and three-tenths we're getting the exact
same
answer just kind of a different way of
approaching it okay for number six now
what did you get for this one we've got
two mixed numbers it's a subtraction
problem
we can do this a couple different ways
let's go ahead and do it the way that we
did first on the number five we're gonna
multiply two times three is six
plus one is seven so it's 7 halves so
we're writing it as an improper fraction
and then 6 times 1 is 6
plus 5 is 11 so that's 11 6. now we just
have to find a common denominator so we
say hmm what's the smallest number that
2 and 6 both go into well that's 6 so
i'm going to multiply
the first fraction by 3 over 3 so that
gives us 21 6
minus 11 6
is equal to
10 6.
but you can see that's an improper
fraction right so 6 goes into 10 once
with 4 left over
and then you can see 4 and 6 who can
reduce that 2 goes into 4 twice 2 goes
into 6 3 times so our final answer is
going to be 1 and two-thirds okay now
for number seven we're multiplying
mixed numbers together so for this one i
would do the same thing i would convert
this into an improper fraction so 5
times 2 is 10 plus 3 is 13 fifths
and then same thing here 3 times 3 is 9
plus 1 is 10
thirds
and now what we can do is we can
multiply horizontally across or we can
do some cross reducing or numerator and
denominator so here i can see that 5 and
10 both have something in common they
both have a 5. 5 goes in here once 5
goes in here twice
now when i multiply horizontally across
i get 26 thirds now you can see that's
an improper fraction how many times does
3 go into 26
8 whole times that's 24 8 times 3 is 24
with 2 left over
so we're getting 8 and 2 thirds okay in
our final problem number 8 we've got 3
and 1 4 divided by 2 and 1 6. so with
division remember how we said we can
keep it change it flip it so we're going
to change the division sign into a
multiplication sign and take the
reciprocal of 2 and 1 6 but first we
have to convert
these
mixed numbers into improper fractions so
let's do that so 4 times 3 is 12
plus 1 is 13 so 13 4
okay divided by 6 times 2 is 12 plus 1
is 13. so 13 6 now we're going to do the
keep it change it flip it we're going to
keep the first fraction change the
division sign to multiplication and take
the reciprocal of the second fraction
now what we can do is we can reduce
numerator and denominator or numerator
and denominator or
numerator and denominator or
numerator and denominator so we're
looking for where we can
reduce a top of a fraction and a bottom
of a fraction and so i think what we're
going to do here is just look at these
13s 13 goes in here once 13 goes in here
once
2 goes into 4 twice 2 goes into 6 3
times now when we multiply horizontally
across
right
we're going to get 1 times 3 which is 3
2 times 1 which is 2.
this is an improper fraction 2 goes into
3 one whole time with one left over so
we get one and one half
so great job if you were able to get all
of those go ahead and put in the
comments you know which how many you got
right and if you want to see some more
examples of working with fractions i'll
put a video on the screen that you can
click and take a look at there otherwise
i look forward to seeing you in the
future videos